all right chris
chris where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
northern california born and raised
bay area
and tell me about your family growing up
yeah mom and dad
my mom and dad
were
separated they separated when i was in
fifth grade
got divorced when i was in sixth grade
and then me my sister my mom moved up to
contra we lived in sunnyvale
and
me and my sister and my mom moved up to
contra costa county antioch near our
grandparents
how would you describe your childhood
my dad was kind of a
strict and rough you know
just wanted me i guess to do right but
you know i wouldn't listen
you went through high school yeah
antioch
you go to college after that no no wait
what kind of work have you done
[ __ ] i've done a lot like to say uh jack
of all trades master of nothing
i've done uh
underground sewer and storm drains
asbestos work
been a grill cook been a security guard
been a
labor performance been a labor
construction sites
painting sandblasting worked in
refineries so i've done all
different things and you're working
currently yes
you have uh wife or kids
no ex-wife uh not the lady that had my
kids we never were married but you have
some kids yes
you raised them
uh she mostly raised them i was
you know yeah in and out and then went
to prison
92 through 97 pretty much
every year 92 to 97
i wasn't out on the streets more than 60
days
did a whole year flat yeah what was what
were we in prison for
being stupid
yeah
i understood
you live in l.a now compton right now i
used to from uh
97
until like
may of this year
i lived in a redondo beach for like 16
years
and then torrance and now i'm over here
in compton yeah
and you go you go to figaro street
sometimes yeah
a lot of girls on up and down that
street right yeah yeah yeah
is that a regular thing for you or
a rarity no it's not always you know in
between medium you know i don't go every
day but i don't go just like once every
six months no right
it's a
and drug use is part of your life as
well oh yeah definitely what's your drug
crack crack so is it the crackiest that
brings you down to figaro street or is
it the girls that make you
want to use the drugs a little both yeah
they go together don't they yeah yeah
that's a common story down there
the girls use you use and it's just a
party right yeah
and uh you go to regulars you have girls
that you frequent regularly or you
change it up sometimes i see
a couple girls i've seen a couple girls
you know two or three times and
sometimes i just pick a different girl
there's a lot of them out there yeah
yeah yeah yeah so you so this is uh like
five in the morning on a sunday morning
you're you were up all night
yep yep
and uh
that
the crack will keep you up like that
right
it'll keep you up it's not like speed
speeds are you know many days
up crack is you gotta keep smoking it
and then crack
um
you keep buying it spending your money
and you stay up but then
i've only stayed up the most times i
stayed up like maybe a day and a half or
two days at the most right what kind of
money do you spend on a weekend smoking
crack
i blow a lot a lot
more than you spend on the girls
probably yeah more than i spend i spend
more on the drugs than on the girls but
it's sometimes it's you know vice versa
right
and is it is it just a
a party for you guys to like hang out
and smoke or is there is there always
sex involved or
oh sex is mandatory with me when it
comes to smoking cracking the [ __ ]
mandatory
you've had any uh crazy things happen
you get robbed you get um taken
yeah a lot a lot of shit's happened a
lot of [ __ ] happened i almost got
stabbed in the face one time in san
francisco
while i was smoking
um
had a truck uh stolen while i was you
know smoking and i parked it and
it was stolen gunpoint
so it was like [ __ ] who stabbed you
in the face
oh i almost got stabbed in the face when
i was smoking because he thought i was
someone else oh i see
and uh i tried to tell him no i'm not
and someone that knew me walked by and
uh
hey tell them what my name is who
you know who i am what my name is
then he apologized but it was like too
late because i already you know the high
was [ __ ] off
and then um
yeah just [ __ ] stuff you know
always
selling [ __ ]
you know
you acquire a bunch of [ __ ] you save up
you know you earn it and then when you
start smoking again you lose it all yeah
yeah
i've heard a lot of stories of guys that
are just spending everything they earn
yeah yeah it can be like that sometimes
yeah
on the drug and the whole scene yeah
yeah it's a really uh
it's a treacherous
world isn't it because it's like you
know some it's not a it's not a fun
place to be in
you know it can be dangerous yeah things
happen very quickly
definitely
but it's just like you know you keep
going back for more
you know it's a never-ending cycle what
do you think it is that draws you down
there
what do you think that makes it
attractive to you
a little both everything right are you
using when you're not down there
no no no no no it's just it's just part
of the
little weekend festivities weekend or
during the week one day one day and
night but no when i'm out of that area i
don't use
you don't no and you you go to work and
you're responsible yeah yeah yeah it's
just this is your weekend or your
frequent [ __ ] off my paycheck or [ __ ]
off whatever money i make i [ __ ] it
off by going down there yeah and then a
day or two later how do you feel about
the whole thing like [ __ ]
like [ __ ] yeah
and drug use has started started for you
viewing what point
when i started using yeah
oh [ __ ] let's see
probably
late 80s
how do you know
i was born in 66 that's making me what
55.
and the fir what what was the first time
you picked up one of the girls
oh god
probably when i was in san francisco
no you know it's a lot easier picking a
hooker up than going in a bar
spending money on drinks for the girl
and you something to eat maybe go to
another bar
and all you'll get maybe the first night
is maybe a phone number
even if that's correct the right number
that she gives you you know so it says
no fuss no muss here's what i want do
you do this do you do that here's the
money let's go
yeah it's very cut and dried very you
get what you want everybody yeah she
gets what she wants i get what i want
everyone's satisfied
at the end of the transaction
some of the time sometimes it just gets
all [ __ ] up where the [ __ ] try to
scam you and
you know
work you and you get nothing in return
so it's just
you just you know it is what it is
does it ever feel empty when it's all
said and done oh yeah lots of times
because it's pretty clear the girls are
doing it for the money yeah yeah yeah or
sometimes they just do for the money you
know you don't get no sex they just work
you
you ever you ever get sweet on any of
the girls you ever fall in love with any
of the girls you meet or get
yeah i have a
one or two times but not all the time no
no no
yeah it's it's interesting how the
different personalities
of these girls you know some some of
them are very attractive they're they're
very nice oh yeah once you get to know
them
and the other ones are just pure
hustlers and
yeah yeah just like
[ __ ] up yeah it's crazy the variety is
is amazing to me yeah
so you were married for how long
about all together
together before we got married and
married all together about
four years
87 was my fault my man up to me is my
fault 87 of it but she's a good woman
she's a good lady i hope the best for
whatever she does you know
so i think i don't have ill feelings
towards her i think it's good to take
responsibility for things like that
yes 87 of it was my fault so you know
yeah even if it's the other person's
fault you still take responsibility for
getting yourself in that situation i
find that helps yeah yeah you know
otherwise you're angry for the next
decade or three yeah yeah yeah
and your kids are uh
doing well
uh
they have some
issues and some troubles but you know
who doesn't yeah they're kids yeah
everyone's
they're older they're in
you know mid-30s
do you have any regrets in your life
[Music]
i wish i hadn't spent so much money and
sold so much stuff that i have through
this
you know addiction yeah i could probably
fill up this whole room with [ __ ] that
you sold oh vehicles vans cars
merchandise everything you name it i've
got it yeah
yeah the behavior of a crack addict is
is
it's like
it's just amazing to once you learn
how far they've gone and what they've
done oh yeah yeah but they've lost yep
it's a very powerful drug isn't it oh
yeah definitely you've tried some of the
other drugs
you've tried some of the other drugs
like crystal meth and things i've tried
uh beans back in the days in high school
with speed pills i didn't like it i i
snorted some speed but i didn't like it
i didn't like it
yeah it's funny how everyone takes to a
certain drug
yeah yeah yeah the people like the
opiates
are loyal to those and then
there's enough other stuff yeah
the the crack
contingent is a very interesting one
though
because the behavior gets so
incredibly scandalous oh yeah definitely
like the people
on crack will do things you just can't
believe they're they're their spouses
can't believe their their kids their
families oh yeah
you name it
crack kids have done it to get whatever
they you know to get their crack yeah
just like heroin acts are the same way
yeah i guess they all kind of but heroin
addicts they need their heroin because
their body actually hurts
when they don't get their fix yeah and
crack it's more mental
yeah crack is more mental so yeah
and do you do you go through withdrawals
during the week when you're not using
no no no
so you you're you're basically a
functional crackheader
functioning at it yeah you know to come
down [ __ ] up so about the next when i
stopped smoking for about the next
16 hours is like you know
a little jittery a little nervous
hopefully no one notices that i'm high
then after that after i get some sleep
and eat a little bit
you know i'm good
so after you know it's five in the
morning from here you're gonna what
go go home and go to bed or go back to
party a bit
i don't know i haven't decided yet i'm
gonna give you money for this interview
so so that'll be a tempting thing for
you right oh definitely
i'll try to steer you in a direction
away from there but we'll see
you have any interesting stories of
things that have happened down there
no i'm also just you know
sex stuff with the [ __ ] you know
pretty much do whatever i want or
anything and everything with them you
know do you do this do you do that what
do you like to do when you smoke i ask
them that yeah you know i tell them what
i like
you know
one time i had two [ __ ]
at the same time um but nothing really
you know
too crazy crazy you know it was like oh
my god i can't believe that really
happened no i did but
no what about diseases
what about sexually transmitted diseases
[Music]
i've had a few of them but you know
medicine is gone yeah you know but these
girls sometimes not from well i guess
from the girl back up in san francisco
but i've been tested and retested every
time i went to the joint
and when i do donation plasma i get
tested for syphilis and aids and hiv
hepatitis so you use condoms when you do
this yes yes
it just it just clears your head if you
do i would imagine oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah otherwise you're worried about
what you might have caught for the next
week
yep
and you guys will go to a room or car or
what kind of stuff sometimes a car
sometimes a room yeah just depends you
know
what's the most you pay
at one time for a girl yeah
and typically it's around 100 bucks
right
yeah a hundred bucks and then you get
the dope and you get more dope or you
want
you you guys quite haven't finished or
you haven't come yet so you want to you
know well if you want me to stay baby
you gotta give me more money that's that
kind of round i've i heard from a lot of
the girls that uh
their favorite
trick is a guy who smokes crack because
they have a hard time
yeah yeah getting it up so your mind
tells you you can do it and you want to
but sometimes your body doesn't function
the way it is supposed to so you end up
paying the girl more money to stick
around yeah yeah and then get you know
she makes lots of money and
there's very little sex involved well
there's sex but you don't get fully
satisfied because you don't go all the
way you know
you don't come or you know me it doesn't
really matter as long as
i just like the sex act itself getting
the attention so whether i come or not
it doesn't really matter as long as i
get the attention from the girl what is
that what do you think you're looking
for is it
that love and connection no just the
sexual attention that's all yeah i'm not
looking for love no
yeah yeah it's it's interesting i've
talked to some of the girls and they're
they they claim they're looking for love
but this is a hell of a hell of a market
to be they love their love no
the only love they want is
a sugar daddy to pay their [ __ ] bills
you know
you know give them money all the time
pay their bills pay their rent yeah well
i think they're probably looking for
love from a pimp or from somebody like
that rather than from one of their
tricks or sometimes they're looking for
sugar daddy some may love their pimp but
the pimp is not going to love them
the way they should yeah that's real
love this is human behavior all he wants
is the money from the girl so he may
tell her he loves her he may tell her
this and that what she wants to hear so
she still works for him and you know
brings him the money yeah do pims come
into play when you pick up the girls
sometimes
not that often sometimes but not a lot
they stay out of the scene yeah they
stay out of this the scene the business
and the girls will tell you they don't
have a pimp yeah yeah
but in fact he's floating around
somewhere
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
don't get started
the drugs don't get started with drugs
any type
gasoline sniffing gasoline was my first
choice
weed
then crack
like they say you always you always
remember the first person that gets you
high and to this day i still remember
the first person that got me high with
crack
so yeah it's you don't get started
that's the most important lesson
no matter if someone says oh you'll be
fine just try it once see if you don't
don't don't don't get started don't let
someone influence you
you know don't let your emotions take
over and [ __ ] it i'm gonna go do this
you know
if you don't do it but the rest of the
people you know do it and you're left
out don't feel bad there you know you're
the smart one
yeah peer pressure yeah don't go by peer
pressure just be yourself
you know right from wrong people you
know people can make you always have a
choice
yeah you know thinking for yourself is
important yeah
all right chris thank you so much for
sharing your story oh no
no problem anytime sir i wish you uh
best of luck i hope you steer away from
figaro street tonight or this morning
thank you man
you